-Mae posted this,
and I think this is definitely
something only
a friend would do.
She basically, on Instagram,
said, "When your co-star
shows up to work
looking like The Rock,"
and then posted a picture of you
side by side by The Rock and...
[ Laughter ]
I talked about this.
She claims she did not
add that fanny pack,
but that seems
very clearly added in, in post.
-We were sitting --
We were shooting --
I forget what scene
we were shooting,
and I was dressed --
This is a costume.
I didn't come to work like this.
[ Laughter ]
This is what
I was wearing on set,
and I was like --
and I was standing there,
and I go, "You guys,
do I look like The Rock?"
and she goes -- she didn't know
what I was talking about.
I was like Google it.
[ Laughter ]
"The Rock fanny pack,"
and she was like,
"Please let me take a picture!"
And then drew in the fanny pack.
-That is fantastic.
Also fantastic,
you wrote a book.
-I did.
-Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I did. Thanks.
"So Close to Being the [bleep]
Y'all Don't Even Know."
How did you come up
with the title,
"So Close to Being the [bleep]
Y'all Don't Even Know"?
-That's just my life.
-Yeah.
-I'm so close
to being the [bleep]
y'all don't even know.
[ Laughter ]
-Don't you feel like people --
more people are getting close
to knowing now every year?
-Well, you know what?
When I was writing this,
I started this
when I was in Vancouver
doing "Girlfriends Guide,"
and that was the kind of thing.
The show was gonna end.
I didn't know if I was gonna
have a job after that.
And it was the kind of thing --
But I was like -- I was antsy.
I was like, "I know,
it's coming, it's coming,
it's coming, it's coming."
And so this job came
after I finished the book.
So there was all this press,
my face was in Times Square,
and I was like,
"The book was right!
A bitch close!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, what I like
about this book is,
obviously, it's very --
you have a very positive
opinion of yourself,
which I think is really healthy,
but you also --
you admit in this book,
there's a whole chapter
where you admit
that you might be lazy.
-Yeah.
-And what are some of the things
where you're admitting
you might be lazy?
-I mean, I sit down
when I'm heating up leftovers
in the microwave.
[ Laughter ]
I sit down in the shower.
'Cause I bought my condo
because the shower had a seat.
[ Laughter ]
I take the elevator at the gym.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
There's another one.
You catch a few Z's
while you pees.
-You know when --
[ Laughter ]
You know when you
go to the bathroom
in the middle of the night,
and you're, like, exhausted?
And, like, I'll pee,
and then you're just, like,
"I don't want to get up."
And then I, like,
fall asleep sometimes.
And then I'm like,
"Oh, I probably should get up,
'cause my legs
are falling asleep."
[ Laughter ]
-"You ever notice
your toenails get too long,
and it's uncomfortable
to wear your own shoes."
[ Laughter ]
-So this is -- you just will
not do toenail maintenance?
-It's because --
I go get mani/pedis,
but sometimes,
like in Vancouver,
I didn't have, like, my person,
and I don't like
randos touching my feet,
and sometimes
they get like that,
and you're like, "Ooh,
these shoes aren't comfortable,"
and it's like,
"Your feet aren't growing.
It's just your toenails."
[ Laughter ]
-I want to ask about this --
If you get engaged --
If you get engaged,
you are gonna register --
You're so lazy, you're gonna
register for Dixie products?
-Yeah, because dishes
are some some bull [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
-So you're just
gonna have paper plates?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The nice kind.
-The nice kind?
-You know,
they have like the hefty ones.
-Dixie Platinum?
Like what --
-You don't think
it's nice sometimes
they have the plastic ones?
-Gotcha.
-You know, just rinse them off
and toss them.
-I would just say,
definitely wait.
Don't mention that after --
like, until you get the ring.
You know what I mean?
That, like,
you're gonna go --
-It's in the book, so hopefully,
he won't read my book.
-Hey, thank you
so much for being here.
It's always just
such a pleasure.